the dps dps
yes i know blue pushes the cart in the
game
we flipped it on its head for the video
it was on purpose i didn't know that i'm
gonna finish assembling and animating
this turret made out of nerf guns
something like that there's different
stories you can tell on team fortress
and there's different ways you can make
a team fortress video it's kind of fun
having your storyline be inspired by the
actual game type that you're mimicking
nerf implies real world so you're
mashing up the real world and the team
fortress world and so we have nerf guns
we have real costumes and it's real
people what would the real world
equivalent of a cart be well
a shopping cart it's like it's all right
it's all right but it could be better
like some of the animations are a little
too fast a couple others are a little
too slow the timing of various
animations in relation to each other is
a little off but i want to have it
actually clumped into the moving shot
before i refine that harley's a cool
dude we've known harley for a while also
six foot five 290 pounds
i feel like harley just gets more and
more legit and more and more i guess
famous and professional it's always nice
to know like there's somebody else out
there you've known for a long time who's
killing it and doing good stuff
here i had a little bit more time i had
a little bit more ability to add
attention to detail to really make like
that turret shot looks sweet the lego
video was particularly hard because
there are so many effects that we had to
do in such a short amount of time from a
technical level this video hasn't been
that hard it is currently
5 16.
we shoot lan party at seven it gives me
one hour and 45 minutes to color grade
this thing team fortress 2 has kind of
this like old-timey james bond slash
adam west batman style thing going for
it i wanted like kind of faded colors
kind of warmer tones film always has
really nice skin tones and skin tones
are always preserved even if everything
else gets funky even i go crazy with
everything else the skin needs to stay
correct so i need to get that in the
right spot hardest part about color
grading is doing it in a fast and
efficient manner the first time i went
through this edit there were a lot more
effects than there are now so that was a
little relieving on this shot i'll just
reverse all the keyframes i think i can
do that i don't actually know how to do
that i'll have to figure that out
samurai are big team fortress fans we
made two team fortress videos before and
they've done really really well and it's
really fun universe to be in because
it's just really cartoon characters
fighting it's not about what's actually
in your hands it's not whether or not
your gun looks real it's about the story
you tell how people act and how you
break it down for your cinematography
and your shooting and editing and sound
sound plays a huge part in action we
start to figure out music don't we hey
nick
what's your friend's name that does
music
daniel
sam as far as costume has this utility
built on this pack and a cord and that
kind of stuff
and he needed to jump into the cart and
sit down you know it's all energetic and
we're all running he does it and the
prongs of the extension cord on his belt
end up jabbing him in the tailbone
he jumps up he's like oh my ass my
tailbone is still jacked up what
happened to your table yeah you got
pronged why is everyone oh my god thanks
brother
you were related like eight generations
back in france i mean we're both white
so maybe somewhere i mean technically
we're all related yeah
the issue that i'm having
is that it's not rendering
it's not working with octane so it
shoots a bunch here they bounce up a
wall harley shoots a bunch it also
bounces off the walnut wall animates
it's great this might be faster on the
other computer so i can continue working
here in after effects i closed it open
up the file everything's broken
so this whole process of troubleshooting
what happened took an hour what i ended
up doing to fix it is i literally just
unlinked them
and then re-linked them so for whatever
reason the act of doing that reset stuff
and then it was able to show an octane
just fine i was like yes i go to hit
render but of course i can't render out
motion blur because for whatever reason
there's another bug there
so i have a shot of nico shooting the
sniper rifle i don't just plan on
getting the shot of me shooting and
that's it you want to think about you
know what's going into it what's coming
out of it the heads and tails of the
shot the camera set up why not just get
everything that happens from that angle
we would rehearse a bigger moment we
knew we'd want to capture one moment
from a certain angle but we'd get
everything from that angle that we could
it's just much easier to do cool little
bits and cool performances and be
invented and just you know get the
emotion going in your face and you know
grit your teeth and have these little
beats we use real smart motion blur and
using a vector pass you can actually do
realistic motion blur it's basically a
colored image that shows this pixel is
moving this direction at this speed it's
literally just information that a
plug-in can use and add blur to
i bring it in empty nothing there i set
it up perfectly i mean had both sam and
eco help me set it up turns out it's
because scanline doesn't work with
octane
that sounds like a simple fix and it is
but it took time to figure that out at
this point this entire day has been
dedicated to this 51 frame
particle simulation of nerf darts so
cinematography is another tool to tell a
story if you have a shaky shot it
imparts a different emotion than a
static shot a close-up says something
different about a person than a wide
shot every shot needs to tell a story he
needs to tell you where to focus it
needs to tell you what emotion to feel
it needs to tell you what logically is
happening in the scene because an action
scene requires logic it's not as
emotionally driven as a dialogue scene
there's a scene where we grab the cart
we start pushing it the very next shot i
cut to is a wide shot that shows us
isolated and alone in this big empty
space i want to show that there are no
other teammates around us and is quiet
it is isolated it is the calm before the
storm so basically the rest of the
effects are the spy transformation shot
the explosion behind nico and various
close-up shots of harley and the guys
shooting
darts just literally animate the start
from here to here like
and then duplicate that offset it i
think that'll be enough so i think i can
finish then there's also all the signs
what
no one told you about the signs no one
tells me anything apparently what do you
mean signs the ending of the video why
do you think we're looking at the top of
the building right uh if you remember
back in the vlogs there's a moment where
sam is saying hey
if we're gonna be the cart people then
you need to bring on the dp carmichael
who you know is the guy literally behind
the camera right now he's been shooting
a lot of stuff from the sam nico channel
he's also been shooting some stuff for
his girlfriend's channel and so his
cinematography skills are getting a
little bit better and i figured you know
what tell carmichael what i need and
trust him to get it done
you're a
fat
boy i'm gonna finish up the signs and
spray paint on the side of target it
shouldn't take longer than two or three
hours i don't have any explicit plans
after that but i kind of want to put
together some sort of effects breakdown
for maybe both nerf and
lego
oh you're looking for an update on the
interns well
good because i'm about to give you one
welcome to paradise
i'm not going to put that in yet